[__] crazy but not yeah and before
that didn't happen because like people
dated more intentionally even even with
the one night stands and like like
people getting pregnant when they were
teenagers like they just get married
before how many our grandparents got
married through shotgun weddings
like you know they just were like oh
[__] okay let's get married and figure
it out my mom and dad they've been
married 17 18 fetish sex Shields yeah
and so even like I don't know people
were just different then it's a
different world I just think birth
control changed the game it changed the
world and I think there's no going back
now